Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new Batman video we just
got this giant news release this morning
so we'll break it down there's a whole
bunch of Easter eggs if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos will do a new Amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and let me know what you
want them to do with this new alternate
version of Batman inside the new movies
so just going down the list starting
with number 5 if you didn't see the news
this morning Michael Keaton himself is
officially in talks to come back as
Batman two words that I want you all to
remember they're very important that if
I leave you with anything I'm going to
leave you with these two words and those
two words are
I'm Batman
they also say that the deal that he's signing
is a Nick Fury type of deal where he would
appear in multiple upcoming DC projects
as his version of Batman I just did a
video about the news of flashpoint
Batman that was released this past
weekend so the trades this morning are
also reporting that Michael Keaton
himself is going to be coming back as an
older version of his Batman from the
1989 movie in Batman Returns the first
movie he's in talks for now is a
multiverse version of the flash movie
which makes a little more sense how you
include his version of Batman and have
it all makes sense because right now we
have the Ben Affleck Batman we have the
Robert Pattinson Batman which is sort of
a reboot of the franchise set in a
slightly different universe there was
all the talk about Jeffrey Dean Morgan
flashpoint Batman this past weekend but
he would be playing his version of
Batman in the flash movie there's no
talk about how many scenes he would have
or how big his role in the story would
be only that this would be part of a
multiverse story that they would tell
during the flash movie the flash is a
very multiverse based character so it's
pretty easy to justify him traveling
between Earth's in the multiverse
there's even video of an interview that
Ezra Miller did a while ago where he
talks about doing multiverse story
inside the flash movie
were really we're starting about, we're talking about
sparking a whole new universe which is
it's not just the DC multiverse it's
also it's the speedster multiverse
and the speedsters are the ones who
connect all of the disparate pieces
he sounds a little bit crazy when he's
talking about it there but you get the
idea it sounds like they're traveling to
multiple different earths inside the
multiverse during the flash movie in one
of those urns will just happen to be
Michael Keaton's earth from the Batman
movies most of you also probably
remember from crisis on Infinite Earths
his Batman actually had a cameo scene
right at the beginning he was literally
one of the first earths that they
traveled to in this big montage at the
beginning of that event
now the entire multiverse is about to come under attack
there is a malevolent force at work one
driven by a singular goal
oh I hope you're watching big guy...
He was on earth 1989 just because that was the
year that his first Batman movie came
out that's Robert Wuhl who played
Alexander Knox in that scene from the
Batman movies reading a newspaper that
he worked at during those movies
detailing Batman just catching the Joker
so it's hard to say when that scene was
actually happening in that timeline
because the original 1989 Batman movie
ended with the Joker dying in their
final fight so make of that what you
will maybe the scene is just meant to
take place right after that happened
before the events of Batman Returns
doing a multiverse type of story inside
the flash movie is also an easy way for
them to do the movie if they're not able
to get Ben Affleck's Batman to come back
to do a cameo scene to tie everything
together
you also have Robert Pattinson Batman
movie in this other universe you have
the Joker movie which is also in its own
separate universe so the multiverse is
just the easiest way to deal with all
these problems what about those other
upcoming DC projects that he would be
involved in they don't specify
live-action or animated so some of them
could be upcoming live-action movies
some of them could be upcoming animated
movies as well with him just doing
voiceover there's the long gestating
live-action Batman Beyond movie that
Warner Brothers almost made after they
were going to reboot the Batman
franchise post Joel Schumacher Batman
with George Clooney
they didn't stop at one
seven against two pretty bad odds...For them.
most of you remember the animated Batman
Beyond series that started during 1999
it was actually a nice trait for that
during crisis on Infinite Earths with
Kevin Conroy's version of Batman he was
on earth 1999 because that was the year
that Batman Beyond came out but he was
also meant to be a version of Kingdom
Come Batman with a darker backstory in
the exoskeleton that he was wearing oh I
never thought I'd get a chance to do it
on camera because I was getting older
and older and older I was sort of aging
out of Batman you know but luckily I
aged into overs Wayne
if you don't remember way back in the
day the live-action Batman Beyond movie
actually goes back to August 2000 Warner
Brothers announced it was developing the
live-action Batman Beyond movie to
refresh the franchise now this was way
before they were talking to Christopher
Nolan about doing his Dark Knight
trilogy they brought on the TV series
creators Paul Dini in Alan Burnett they
were writing a screenplay for a feature
film Neal Stephenson was hired as a
consultant they turn in their first
draft of the script in 2001 but then by
August 2001 the studio put those plans
on hold and then started planning what
would eventually become Christopher
Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy they
explained that that version of a
live-action Batman Beyond would have
been super dark nihilistic lots of
swearing in violence and it wasn't going to
be the pg-13 type of Batman that Warner
Brothers is known for putting out the
only rated R Batman film that you're
going to find is actually the animated
film based on the Killing Joke but we
have Robert Pattinson Batman movie
coming up with Matt Reeves next year we
all talk about how do you redo the
Batman franchise refresh everything
without making it feel exactly like the
same thing that came before I've already
done a lot of videos about that movie
but one of the other fresh ways to
handle the Batman character that they've
never done before in the movies or the
live-action TV shows is Batman Beyond
probably the easiest slam dunk movie
that they could do and if they feel like
they don't want to make a full-blown
live-action Batman Beyond movie it will
be the perfect HBO max series seriously
Batman Beyond HBO max series do six to
eight episodes do like four to five
seasons if AT&T is trying to get people
to subscribe to HBO max and pay for that
service that would be one of the easiest
ways to do it a live-action Batman
Beyond
with Michael Keaton's Batman deadline is
also reporting that they would use
Michael Keaton's Batman in the upcoming
Batgirl movie which is apparently still
in development Joss Whedon was the one
that started that project but then he
left saying that he just couldn't come
up with a convincing idea for it
they didn't say when the Batgirl movie
would take place they haven't cast an
actress for that yet they didn't say if
it be tied to any of the Justice League
or DC EU films that they're doing right
now
Batgirl isn't really a multiverse type
of character all of her stories are
pretty straight up just like regular
Batman movies so we don't see them using
a lot of multiverse twists in that movie
whatever it winds up being so for now I
would just assume that whichever Batgirl
that they do if he's going to be in it
she would just be the bat girl from his
earth the only back row that we've seen
so far was during the Schumacher films
and technically that's not the same
Batman from the Michael Keaton films you
kind of to treat it like it's off in its
own universe just because things change
so much even though it's the same
version of Alfred so you could argue
that it's meant to be the same Batman
just played by a different actor but I
think it's best users consider that
that's happening on a different earth in
the multiverse just because there are
too many inconsistencies in other places
between all those different films and
here's another big one two other
high-profile upcoming DC projects we
keep wondering how they're going to handle
Robert Pattinson Batman if they did a
future Justice League movie but could
you imagine them using an older Michael
Keaton Batman in the next Justice League
movie instead of Robert Pattinson using
a multiverse twist Warner Brothers
hasn't really said anything about what
they plan on doing with the next Justice
League in terms of Robert Pattinson Matt
Reeves has implied that his Batman
trilogy is meant to be off in his own
little thing so there were a lot of
journalists this morning referring to
the Michael Keaton Batman that's
supposed to be coming back now into the
DC movies as being the Justice League
Batman and Robert Pattinson Batman just
kind of being off in his own separate
thing and he would not be the one to
cross over in future Justice League
movies but without Warner Brothers
officially releasing plans for what that
next Justice League is I think most of
that's just speculation let me know in
the comments though would you rather see
older Batman Michael Keaton's show up in
the next Justice League movie and just
be that Justice League Batman or would
you rather see Robert Pattinson Batman
from the bat
franchise come into the new Justice
League film for the most part when
people talk about Michael Keaton coming
back as the character though they're
talking about live-action Batman Beyond
just because he's aged into that older
Batman so would just be a lot easier for
them to justify having him on screen
looking like he does with a version of
Terry McGinnis being introduced and it's
easier to do that movie when you have
other Batman movies in present-day like
Robert Pattinson --zz Batman movie that
it says so far in the future that you
don't really have to worry about
continuity issues and even though it's
funny to include clips of the Grant
Gustin Ezra Miller cameo scene during
crisis on Infinite Earths just in terms
of other multiverse stuff if we're
talking about a big multiverse flash
story in the flash movie it's totally
possible that they could find their way
to have a Grant Gustin cameo during that
right now that movie is set to start
filming sometime early next year but
when we get more information about that
of course I'll do a video and if you
weren't excited about the flash movie
before the idea of Michael Keaton Batman
showing up in that and then also showing
up in other future DC movies just feels
so cool I mean we were talking about
flashpoint Batman this past weekend and
he's a cool version of Batman but
getting Michael Keaton to come back as
Batman something that he said he would
probably never do just feels like the
most amazing thing ever
so everyone post all your theories in
the comments what other upcoming DC
movies do you want them to use older
Michael Keaton Batman in I know you're
all probably going to say live-action
Batman Beyond but let me know there any
others too while you wait for everything
click here for my Justice League Snyder
cut trailer video and click here for
that video from crisis on Infinite
Earths of his cameo scene in all those
Easter eggs thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe
I'll see you guys tonight!